[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here and new phone
this is the zte axon 20 5g so you might
have heard of this phone already but
also probably not it's a fairly standard
newish mid-grade phone and looking at it
you might not notice anything super
different it's a big phone of course it
does have this orange faux leather
finish quad cameras on the back pretty
big display
doesn't look like anything too crazy we
haven't seen before
well except one thing this phone does
have one thing we've never seen before
in any other phone it's actually up here
at the top
you can kind of catch that maybe how
about if we maybe if we zoom in a little
bit maybe you can see it a little better
now
or if we switch to a macro camera you
can kind of see it ah there it is
now you can see what i'm talking about
so this phone has the world's first
under display
selfie camera if we weren't in the
middle of a global pandemic i would love
to do a video going out to people on the
street and handing them this phone and
saying you notice anything different
about this screen
because i just feel like almost no one
would actually pick up on it because if
you're not looking for it
it's almost invisible but the second you
notice it
you can't unnotice it but we all knew
this was coming we've seen multiple
parts of smartphones work towards this
perfect all screen phone thing for a
while now we saw the fingerprint reader
go from the button to underneath the
display we even saw speakers on some
phones go from above the display to
right behind it vibrating through the
glass so the last thing left which is
also the hardest thing has been the
camera so our eye has gotten kind of
used to all these notches and cutouts
and hole punches in almost every new
smartphone display these days somewhere
around the top either in the middle or
the corner that's just a cut out a hole
in the screen you're gonna have to have
for the selfie camera and there were
other methods like pop-up cameras of
different sizes and shapes and while
they technically did help achieve the
goal of the seamless front display thing
and i happen to really like them for the
security benefit of blocking the selfie
camera when it's not in use it was a
loss in pretty much every other category
to the manufacturer it's a moving part
in a phone which introduces higher
probability of a failure point it's
worse and more difficult for
waterproofing it costs more it takes up
more space in the phone so i liked them
but they've been kind of a work around
the whole time so this was the
inevitable thing that new technology
that would allow us to put the camera
behind the display and now that i've
actually used it and looked at it
i can see why no one else has shipped it
yet so first of all it's not a super
high-end display it's a nice screen but
it's not super bright it's a 6.9 inch
pretty big oled at 1080p and 90 hertz
fine it's a 4 to 500 phone but right up
there at the top you can see there's
something a little different going on
and when you really look for it well
it's really obvious so let's get
technical for a second to explain what's
actually happening here there are a few
things necessary to make this happen you
have the 32 megapixel camera itself
back there inside the phone then you
have basically a notch cutout in the
display but the display itself continues
over this notch in essentially half the
pixel density so 720p equivalent
resolution with smaller pixels so
there's actually space between the
pixels for the camera to see through and
then when you actually open the selfie
camera and it's on there's a driver
manipulating those remaining pixels to
make them semi-transparent and lastly
there's literally a defogging algorithm
running to help the camera software
figure out what's behind those
semi-transparent pixels then it merges
it all together into one image
and that image
is not great
it's impressive that it works of course
but the selfies are soft like charmin
soft they look like uh the lens maybe
had like some fingerprints smeared over
it or something but no this is this is
the way it looks this is the image the
camera produces now how much of that is
due to the fact that this is a 400
zte phone selfie camera
versus the fact that it's a brand new
one-of-a-kind selfie
camera technology hard to say
but i mean this is like literal best
case
world-class lighting situation and this
is how it looks so it's clear that
there's a bit of an image quality
trade-off here most of the noticeably
bad parts of these selfies is in the
highlights so like anytime there's
bright light or something where a lot of
light should be shining through the
semi-transparent pixels well you can
start to see the semi-transparent pixels
that aren't quite disappearing and kind
of add a haze to everything you can even
pull the white notification shade over
the selfie camera while the video is
recording and see pretty much all of
those pixels light up which is crazy the
trade-off is real but if that's the
trade-off just to hide the camera then
the real question is how hidden is the
camera and uh it's a different answer
for different even i'm looking at it now
it's it's different in different
situations so when the camera is off and
you have a dark image or something sort
of dark happening at the top of the
display it's impressively hidden like
it's actually pretty good and if you're
if you're looking for it you'll see it
but most of the time you're looking at
the display head-on at other stuff and
it's not distracting it's kind of like
the notch or the hole punch camera it
just disappears to your eye after a
while but even more since the image goes
right over the notch i think it looks
best in this case but what i noticed is
the lighter the pixels or the brighter
the ui the more jarring those pixels get
and because now the half resolution and
all the gaps between the pixels are way
more contrasted and obvious here so
whether you're looking at it straight or
at an angle if stuff is bright it's
going to be visible like this is you can
see here what it looks like when i pull
down the notification shade over it you
can see this is maybe worst case
scenario but like the pixel by pixel row
lag and the the pixelation of everything
happening here so yeah it's clearly
nowhere near perfect but for a first
version
it feels about right you know for as
much as we talk about other companies
like the samsungs and apples of the
world they would never ship this and so
we need companies like zte to be taking
that tech risk and to be putting the
stuff out there to get that ball rolling
because now we actually have something
to work with and judge the quality of a
new tech on this is this is really
interesting stuff so now my big thought
while testing this is
how much better can it get
and will it actually get better quickly
because when you think about it all
these other under display technologies
that we've been working with with
smartphones for the last few years
started off bad and then got on this
curve getting pretty good quickly the
under display speakers started off bad
today they are slightly quieter and
slightly more muffled than a regular
speaker but they're pretty close they're
pretty close the under display
fingerprint readers again started off
slow but they're close now they're just
slightly slower and slightly less
reliable than the old gold standard
touch id button so it's no surprise that
the first under screen selfie camera is
bad but how long before it's only a tiny
bit softer and hazier than a normal
selfie camera then how fast does it get
good i actually got to speak briefly
with some of the people who are
literally working on this and they're
already working on future generations of
this tech that we'll see better in later
phones and they are very confident
confident that they can hide this better
with better pixel matching and better
lines of resolution but
again that's uh the other half is how
good will the picture quality look but
here's another question
what does this mean
for privacy
like if this technology gets really good
what does this mean for like how screens
of the future will look like my initial
thought was oh now if we don't know
where the selfie camera is in a phone we
won't really know where to look when
taking a selfie like will we look at the
side or the corner or maybe it's in the
middle someday
but to be honest you probably just
correct the way the eyes look with
software facetime already does this
surface pro x already does this so
that's that's not even new but does that
mean laptops of the future will be able
to put the selfie camera
anywhere maybe further from the edge in
the middle
and can they be on any time like if i
don't have an indicator of any type
i it could just be on all the time like
imagine a hotel room tv
with a camera behind it
that's terrifying so that's definitely
something i'm going to be keeping an eye
on i think the next logical step when
this stuff starts to happen more often
is to add an indicator light in the
software somewhere so that we know when
the camera is on like like ios did so
there's less privacy concerns and i can
feel as comfortable at least as i did
with those pop-up selfie cameras but let
me know what you think of this whole
idea of putting the camera behind the
display i was originally gonna ask like
do you think it's worth it do you think
hiding the camera is worth the worse
image quality but i think in this first
one it's
it's pretty clear no it's not worth the
trade-off
but my question to you is in the future
if this gets really good do you actually
even want your your display to be hidden
do you really want that full screen
beautiful phone
at the expense of not knowing where the
camera is let me know what you think and
shout out to today's video sponsor the
ridge wallet a sleek industrial
lightweight modern wallet so it doesn't
bulge out but it doesn't have to it's
just a modern wallet unlike what most
people have been carrying which was
designed a long time ago once you
realize you don't need to be carrying
around receipts and pictures and gift
cards you might as well upgrade to a
modern wallet to match your modern
wallet situation so the ridge wallet
holds up to 12 cards plus room for cash
there's over 30 colors and styles at
this point including stuff like carbon
fiber or titanium and it's well built to
the point where they also offer a
lifetime warranty so you could buy this
one wallet and carry it for life which
is pretty sweet there's also a 45-day
return policy so if you buy it use it
and somehow don't like it you can return
it for all your money back so all you
have to do is go to ridge.com mkbhd to
shop and see all the different colors
and finishes and stuff like that and if
you use the code mkbhd at checkout you
actually get 10 off your order and
there's also free worldwide
international shipping which is dope so
you can check it out at the link below
and shout out to ridgewallet for
sponsoring this video
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace
you